you're talking about
the degree to which Pharma yes uh not
only influences but has effectively
fully captured journals medical schools
medical associations uh governmental
Regulators all of the pieces of the
puzzle necessary to create a totally
fictional world yes which is what they
tried to do during covid yes and so I
call this the Pharma game and they and I
think part of what people don't get is
yeah you know 20 years ago we all knew
Pharma was a problem right and like you
we all believed oh it's probably
altering the science enough to matter
yeah not writing it at a whole cloth
right exactly
um so we're looking what we're really
looking at is
The evolutionary product of the world we
all thought we lived in right Pharma
having too much influence over
Regulators instead of it is The
Regulators it is effectively the
puppeteer
and it is moving these puppets around to
create the impression that science is
being done to ensure the safety of the
public it's not true 100
impression creates the impression
absolutely creates the and it's worse
than nothing right because the thing is
if you didn't have regulators
right if all you had was your doctor
and a bunch of pills your doctor would
be in a position to notice and to
discuss with other doctors hey I don't
think that pill is safe maybe stay away
from that one but the impression that is
created through the journals and through
this phony scientific work
um actually causes I'm sure it causes
doctors to override their doubts about
safety right how could it not maybe I'm
seeing you know maybe the pattern I'm
seeing isn't really a pattern maybe it's
sampling error and I know that because
hey here's a large study that seems to
suggest exactly the opposite well that's
exactly it right I mean the doctors you
know when I think about medicine I mean
not really my career but if you look at
the history of medicine like you know
some of the seminal books from the
subject I mean the pharmacopee at that
time the amount of medicines that we're
using in disease I mean it was very
small right now you have huge amount of
medicines right all coming through
Pharma funded trials and all that and
your your point is is correct I mean the
average doctor you know they essentially
they have an implicit faith and trust
into that those institutions right the
journals and
and the the the people who do the
studies and they think that there's an
Integrity there's a Code of Ethics
there's you know all of these things
and they'll believe what they're told
and what's shocking to me Brett is how
much
they so easily believed
that was break you know so like one
thing let's say you talk about arguments
and hydroxycorkum we know that doctors
are too busy they don't really read
studies critically
um they'll read the abstract first of
all even to read studies critically I
mean you really have to say like what
didn't they put in this paper like what
is missing like there's so much things
that you find out when you really think
about a paper and you know all these
anomalies like they'll present certain
data in certain papers and leave it out
of others you have to ask it why they
leave it out you know and so but doctors
they read abstracts and you know and
especially an abstract from the top a
medical journal in the world I mean that
abstract is thus truth right it's almost
like one of the you know the Ten
Commandments from The Mountaintop right
and and
and how much they just
you know like I guess I use the example
of like for me
like this unveiling right of the scope
and the scale of this capture and
control you know was slow I mean it was
slow and iterative during covet I mean I
was learning these I was finding these
astonishing and really disturbing facts
of these things that they were just
divorcing themselves from even pragmatic
science or even you know if these were
policies divorced from science and I was
like how can they do this how are they
getting away with this and I will tell
you the the day that I remember being
really the most upset and Disturbed was
the day that the FDA put on their
website that there's no evidence to
support checking antibodies before
vaccination you know when when the
vaccines came out like my my good
friends and colleagues like who were
internists who had offices right their
patients were coming to them for
guidance around the vaccine and I mean I
mean their initial gut reaction was like
taking history did you have covet right
that would be one way or check
antibodies and so like one of my
colleagues he was checking antibodies
and if you had a positive antibody you
can skip the vaccine but here we had you
know a governmental agency telling the
entire country of doctors
that this thing called natural immunity
which we've which is as an evolutionary
biologist Brad I think you can speak
about natural immunity more than most I
mean this is literally how we've
survived right uh through history and
viruses and you know organisms and
suddenly
some words on a website and the entire
country just goes with it without
critical questioning without a
discussion I mean there was some stuff
around that but like how did they cancel
or disappear natural immunity with one
page of a website
I mean you know I I the worst story I've
heard not the worst I I don't want to
qualify like that but I had a patient uh
once about a year ago she was a a
pharmacist who worked at a hospital and
she told me that the hospitalists at
that hospital were vaccinating covid
patients upon discharge
wow and yeah that to me was a wow moment
I said wait a second you know because
there is a some precedent to that like
with flu like people come in for some
other reason during the flu seasons and
you know the doctors will offer them a
flu shot because they're captive right
there it's like hey you're here we'll
give you a flu shot so flu shots kind of
you know is like kind of a checklist
upon discharge so like I get that but
here you had patients admitted for covid
survived covid
still probably a little rocky not all of
them are well but they're ready to go
home
and you're going to vaccinate them with
an old protein that was the other thing
it was like late 2021 guys we're using a
two-year-old protein and anyway your
your answer that when you said wow that
that was what I said that day I just I
literally was like what is going on the
world has gone mad well it's
incredibly foolish for multiple
independent reasons
right on the one hand
and and I guess the the thing that's
really frightening about this is anybody
who's gone through medical school
ought to be able to piece one if not
both of these together
one
the history of vaccine safety is not a
clean record until 2020. there are lots
of cases where vaccines that were
promising did not get through safety
trials because they were dangerous and
there are cases in which vaccines that
were released were withdrawn because
they turned out not to be safe right so
the idea that vaccines are safe is Dead
on Arrival that is not a true idea right
if vaccines are safe it's because we're
good at the safety process
in this case you had so-called vaccines
that were a highly novel in their
mechanism of action
really unprecedented
and B the safety testing at best was
truncated by time and there is no way to
accelerate safety testing because part
of what you're looking for are long-term
effects and so there's no way to know
that there wasn't something lurking five
years out
right so a doctor
should be interested in taking anybody
off the list of candidates that they can
take off without a cost even if these
vaccines were highly effective and there
were no harms that had been spotted you
should still want to vaccinate as few
people as you have to
because the potential of hurting
somebody in some way that we didn't yet
understand was something you couldn't
take off the map so natural immunity
that should be like oh what a relief we
don't have to take any risk with you
because you got through it your immunity
is going to be better than this vaccine
which provides one antigen it's not
broad it's it's almost stupidly narrow
it's an old antigen right from a variant
that is no longer circulating so thank
goodness we can take you off the list
and not expose you to that risk every
doctor should have seen that and then on
the other side the part that's maybe
harder to spot
is
you're dealing with a layered set of
complex systems
what happens when you take somebody who
has just recovered from the current
circulating version of a disease and you
inoculate them with something that
triggers the production of a closely
related antigen while their immune
system has not fully stood down from the
infection it just beat right does that
make them more susceptible in the future
does it make them less does it cause the
immune system to think that it has
failed to fight off the infection and to
go into some kind of overdrive that we
don't understand there are a dozen ways
that could go wrong it's super complex
and and then the related uh question
which we've explored a little bit is
what do you what happens when you give
someone a vaccine for that narrow old
antigen which is now quite different
right it's mutated it's not the right
and we know a little bit about that with
flu because that they've always done you
know they're always a day late and a
dollar short with the flu vaccine but
this was
this is even more I think it's even more
mutagenic than the flu I mean this thing
was rapidly changing rapidly changing I
think in part or in large part because
of the vaccination campaign itself which
creates an almost absurdly concentrated
evolutionary pressure which drives the
virus around
but in any case the obvious caution that
should attend medicine when confronting
a novel therapy
right
was simply not there the desire it was
like a religious desire to vaccinate
people rather than a hey we've got no
choice we've got to do a lot of
vaccination but let's figure out who
doesn't need it right
you know you Brad I mean you're making
these the way you lay that out right it
just makes so much sense it's pragmatic
it's prudent those are all principles
that you would think a doctor would
employ a physician would employ and
let's be fair though Brad you know what
you're the reason that you just
articulated
this there's a percentage of doctors who
did approach and I think thought of it
that way some very tiny numbers stood
firm and stuck to those principles
but if you look at the the
population of physicians in this country
I think there's a large percentage who
just believed what they were told that
they didn't have critical thinking but
the one that's most troubling is that
percentage and I know what percentage
that is who knew this was wrong and were
coerced and co-au they realized they
couldn't put up resistance if if you did
you were going to be shunned and
vilified and even unemployed right I
mean if if you were in your office and
you worked for an employer and you
started telling patients come you don't
need the vaccine you don't need the
vaccine I mean you're not around long
and those who thought it was the right
thing because all the the fouches and
the experts and all the societies were
telling you to vaccinate everyone so you
thought you were doing you know the best
science I think there's a lot of
Physicians who literally thought like
because the expert said so
it's the right thing to do
um the best scientists and the best
Minds in the country in medicine are
telling us to vaccinate anything that
moves
um so let's do it but there was a
proportion I think that thought like you
Brett and and they went along anyway
[Music]
foreign